the wood is changing first of all wanted
to congratulate you two on the success
of Black Panther there was a box-office
success but then there was the fan
reaction we changed history it changed
probably how we're gonna do film from
now on what was the milestone for you
that met the most it has to be personal
interactions with people that's the real
meaningful thing for us just seeing the
impact that had on and on people there
was something very powerful about you
know hearing how it was being responded
to and how people were celebrating it as
they would go to it and I celebrate
themselves their cultural their
specificity was something that I had
never seen in my life just seeing
everybody just talk about the film and
be so proud and like having the Black
Panther challenge and people dancing and
buying tickets for little kids to go and
see it seeing everybody just come
together to support the film that for me
was the mouse I'm proud to be part of a
world that I can be sitting here with
with them and that is willing to make
different kinds of movies that are more
inclusive
it's a salute it's a citation which Ryan
and I came up with in the program your
left has to be first okay then your
right goes okay so every time you see
each other you like put your right hand
over your left for you got it we do in
Cherie yes yeah yeah but I can't do it
by myself way she's gotta do the
handshake came from the fact that we
were we're both royalty and we're
greeting each other
T'Challa we need something special just
for us and he said let's do it and I was
like okay cool
so we're gonna do this where we slide we
click and then we do like that and it's
just like it's all little things like
that so you slide click and go like that
but it has to be smooth smooth and it
has to be sensual
[Music]